- So, there was this guy
in like seventh grade
that had a crush on me.
He would kind of like follow
me during school a lot
just because he liked me
and I saw him at lunch,
you know just like,
he was hiding behind a trash
can kind of like staring at me
and I like went up to him
and I said I hate you,
why do you exist?
Since that day on, he didn't
talk to me or anything
and this is the probably worst thing
I've ever said to anyone, so.
I felt really guilty afterwards.
I didn't really say that
I was sorry or anything
because I was just like in middle school
and it made me look cool
so I thought it was okay
to say things like that
but now looking back at it,
I hope it didn't follow him or anything.
If I saw him today, I would
just like to say sorry
and that he's worth something
and that he's an important person.
- Most painful thing
I've ever told someone
was when I was 19 years old
and I told my parents that
I was molested by my brother
and they didn't believe me.
And it took 20 years later
for my brother to apologize on his own
and my mom to this day
still doesn't believe me.
That's the most painful thing.
- [Interviewer] You are so comfortable
with talking about it,
what has got you to this point?
- Therapy.
Therapy and talking about it
and knowing that,
knowing that the shame is not mine,
knowing that
I was young.
I didn't, he was older,
when I spoke up I did what
a 19 year old would do,
go to support
and when I didn't get
it, I kept looking for it
because my life mattered and it still does
and I share it pretty
comfortably these days.
- So a couple years
ago, I lost my daughter
and everybody had a very strong
connection with my daughter
and it was heartbreaking
to have to tell each and
every person individually
what happened to her and why she passed.
She passed away of SIDS,
sudden infant death syndrome.
Yeah, she had a heart condition
that was passed on from me,
so yeah it was heartbreaking.
- I told my dying mother
that I no longer want her in my life,
that I can no longer support her
and give her the love and
affection that she wants
'cause she ruined too many chances.
And when she died, I never said goodbye.
I think happiness is
the most selfish thing
that anyone can do and
sometimes finding your happiness
means you gotta make those tough decisions
and let people go.
Sometimes happiness isn't always sunshine
and you know, smiles,
sometimes it's rain and pain
and suffering and moving on
and struggling.
And I think it really helped
define me and who I am
and the happiness that I'm
trying to create for myself
and it was tough but it was
the best decision for me.
- So, it's not like a single thing,
but I used to kinda bully
my brother and call him fat
and now I wish that I was
more supportive of him
and didn't matter what
he looked like nothing
now I feel he looks more,
feels more comfortable
about his body image,
but I feel like for a long time
I was part of the problem
with his body image
and I don't feel good about that.
- [Interviewer] Have you
expressed this to him?
- You know, now I talk to him about
how I would only like to support him
but I've never actually told him
that I felt bad for
pretty much bullying him
when we were younger.
- In like Freshman year, I just like,
I broke up with a girlfriend over text.
Like it was the most terrible
way to break up with anybody.
I'm not like this person
anymore obviously,
you go through changes
and I became a different person you know,
but I was like, your
ex-boyfriend's really hot,
she was like which one,
I was like me.
That was a very painful thing to say.
I think it was a reckless,
not really caring
and just like, too joking in a way
that you didn't really care
about other people's feelings, you know.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what changed?
Do you think that now you
actually do care about people's feelings?
- Well, I was like
realizing that you know,
it really matters how
you treat other people.
You know, if you're not treating
anything like it's you too.
- [Interviewer] So like
treating everyone like you do.
- Everything as it is yourself, yeah.
- Saying I love you to my dad.
I hadn't said I love you to my dad
in like a really long time
and when I said it during our argument,
I just like, it didn't feel right
and I just don't think I
ever wanna say it again
unless I know it's
coming from a good place.
So, I think that's it for me.
- Before, now you can't really tell,
but I used to be a little rounder,
a little bit more chubby
and a lot of people would tell me like
oh, you lost a lot of weight.
Some people think I've lost
the weight in a healthy way
but the way I actually lost
it was really unhealthy
and I was just in a really bad,
I was in a bad time in my life
and I just straight up
could not consume food
or eat anything.
So the most painful
thing that I experienced
was having to actually and
truly explain how I lost weight.
It was painful for me to explain
because it's just kinda like, oh
yeah that's the reality of it
and that's actually how I lost everything,
like all the weight.
But we're good now.
We're good now, we're thriving.
- I really mad and I told like,
I told my family as a whole
that they were doing bad
job at being a family.
Like I don't know what I was saying,
I was kinda like mad.
Like I love my family and we fight a lot
but they do everything for me
as much as they can.
I talked to them that day,
I was like okay, I'm sorry
I didn't mean to say that.
'cause I can't go to bed,
well I can go to bed being mad at them
but I can't go to bed
having them feel that way about me, upset.
- The most painful
thing I've told somebody
is I've cheated on you.
Something I kinda think
about a lot actually
and how wrong it was
and
how sorry I am.
And it kind of effects where I'm at today.
- [Interviewer] Did they forgive you?
- I don't think so.
- I'm
that I'm (giggling)
okay wait.
Okay (clears throat).
It was
coming out as not entirely straight
to my boyfriend
and the only reason it was just so painful
is 'cause growing up, my
family always kind of teased me
that I was
gay
and so I never wanted to admit to myself
and
so I've only came out to my boyfriend
and nobody else
just 'cause I don't want them
to have sort of satisfaction
that they were always right.
I
haven't quite admitted that to my family
and some of the people closest to me
but I don't really, I'm not
ashamed of it, so, yeah.
- The last time I saw my grandma,
she was joking with me about seeing my dad
and I blew her off
and then like a week later, she died.
I really really loved her
and as a kid growing up I
couldn't speak that much Spanish
and there was like a
language barrier with us
but she would always
call me el chico comico
or something like that
or she would always just like
be really really nice to me
and I just felt like I couldn't
be like a good grandchild
and I feel like now I singing
a lot in Spanish and stuff
so it's just like I feel
like now that I'm older
I'm trying to at least
like honor her in that way.
- The most painful thing that
I'll probably tell somebody
is to my real dad,
is that I hated him.
It just really hurts like,
'cause he tried to treat me better
and I just didn't let him
and I told him that I hated him
before when he passed away.
- So about eight and a half years ago,
my husband was hit by a
car while riding his bike
and everything basically was
broken from here to his pelvis
and I had the job of calling
his then 90 year old father
to tell him what happened to his son
and it's really hard to
hear a 90 year old guy
who's a World War II vet
ball on the telephone
and I had to keep him posted
through the whole recovery
and to this day I cannot
call him on the phone
because whenever I call and he answers
he thinks something's
really horrible has happened
so someone else has to call
him and hand me the phone
because he still can't have me call him.
You realize that being
a parent never stops
that he was still a 90
year old man with a son
and probably still sees
his son as his little boy
and he's hundreds of miles away
and his kid's in a hospital broken
and yeah it was a pretty
pretty poignant moment.
- [Interviewer] Is it you?
(laughing)
okay, so how does it make
you feel hearing that story?
- It reminds me of the whole situation.
Everything she says about you
never stop being a parent.
One that jumps out at me
and I can't believe it still
bothers me to this day.
12 years ago or more, my
daughter who's in her 30s now,
was in college and she
was giving short answers
to family members when they'd call
and just really not being too interested
and instead of actually asking her
what was going on or whatever,
I read her Riot Act over the phone
and brought her to tears
and I felt so terrible for doing that
and she couldn't, she could
barely talk at the other end
because I did that.
So, there's a series of
phone calls afterwards
where we made amends and all that stuff
but she was so far from
home it seemed like
and I couldn't believe that I made her cry
over something so trivial.
Yeah, that's it.
- Okay,
when we were going to
help my sister's boyfriend
propose to my sister,
my brother and I got into
a fight on the way up there
and I told him that her
fiance didn't even like him
and that he wasn't really
a part of the family
and stuff like that.
It was really awful.
Like the moment it came out of my mouth,
I was like oh my god,
can't believe I would ever
say something like that.
Especially in such a
beautiful moment you know.
They're best friends
and my brother looks up to him so much
so it was a really low jab.
He got really silent and that's how I knew
that I had like really crossed the line
because usually he would
like yell at me or react.
I pretty much apologized
like the moment it came out of my mouth
'cause I realized that was just awful.
So, yeah, we're good now though.
It makes me more conscious
of everything that I say
because I've seen how
hurt other people can be
by just your words.
- So, I think reversing the question
which is what we did on today's episode,
really shines light on the
fact that we're all human
and sometimes we make bad decisions
and use the wrong words.
And obviously that's not okay,
that's not what I'm saying,
but you can still be a good person
who makes bad decisions
and the important thing is to realize
that you did something bad
or did something hurtful
and try not to do it again
and obviously ask for forgiveness.
So, that's pretty much it.
Thank you guys for watching
and I'll see you next week.